[Music]
tell us mr. Wayne I want to do you here
how do you know my name
the world is too small for someone like
Bruce Wayne to disappear
your parents death was not your fault my
parents deserve justice I cannot let
that pass if you make yourself more than
just a man then you become something
else entirely
yes hell legend must I mean
mom's - wait you'd call me back for long
sir as long as it takes to show the
people of Gotham their city doesn't
belong to the criminals and corrupt
bris Rachel y'all got a long time yeah
these are worse than ever down here what
chance does Gotham have when the good
people do nothing no makes a liable suit
for Vance infantry Kevlar utility
harness gas-powered magnetic grapple gun
tumbler oh you wouldn't be interested in
that
of time being scared for you I heard you
were back
I left the man who vanished never came
back
he's here who the Batman
got that must be justified
Gotham isn't beyond saving
the total
[Music]
gaaah dresses up like a bat clearly as
issue
[Music]
and